let's go next to our caller from the
3:01
area code 301 if you can hear me go
ahead hello
the pac-man by name is total kana you
who just mind if they cannot make each
fan okay thank you if we're on speaker
please take us us off I didn't quite
catch your name there okay how about
this is better that is so much better
thank you okay well the reason that I
wanted to ask something about that is
that I wanted to know your opinion about
the a pro-life movement even though I am
a Christian I am pro-choice simply
because I feel that the pro-life
movement is a little pro-white because I
feel that they they say that patek you
know the fetus and protecting all that
but they don't seem to come out for
black lives matter dreamers LGBT
community or even the dream or anything
in particular so I want to know what
your thoughts were wow you sound a
little out of breath
let me see if but you're you're saying
what do I believe that the pro that the
anti-abortion movement is a pro white
movement it's a pro white movement
because because my understanding is that
they don't seem to do any kind of reach
out to protect the lives of African
Americans Hispanics or LGBT folks well
they claim what they are they in fact
one of the arguments from the pro-life
community is that it's
disproportionately black babies that
were aborted and that the black
community should be against abortion
because they would have a much more
vibrant and plentiful population were it
not for abortion so I think it's sort of
a bogus argument but they claim that
they are very much Pro minority by being
against abortion but but that's simply
not true of course it's true
why would essentially want pro-life
would mostly be Republicans want more
black and brown people right the
population because that means that most
one will go towards Democrats yeah oh
it's laughable obvious they don't want
that but that's how they couch it listen
I don't know if it's a pro white
movement the thing for me is it's a
movement that I don't need to assess in
terms of its racial goals
to know that I'm against it right so I
think that there are numerous other
reasons to oppose the so-called pro-life
movement which I call the anti-choice
movement I don't know whether it's
definitively a pro-white movement you're
probably onto something if you look at
the demographics of that movement but
but I think there's an any number of
other good reasons to oppose the
pro-life movement okay thank you sir all
right appreciate the call thank you very
much